how you doing
hi how are you how are you i'm okay how
are you i'm darlene you own the car i do
yes here's what happened
i was parked up on the median you see
where i park up there or not yeah i do
we have license plate readers on the car
it hit on your plate as being expired
and suspended but it's not it's really
not no what i'm saying is it says
suspended dude insurance cancellation
right but it is expired 722 last month
but it's not yeah are you talking about
with this what wait
yeah what happened is my car in there
trying to handle that
i went to court for
um
um my registration i can't get it
i can't get it inspected until they
yeah i'm not even i'm not even not
worried about the inspection right it's
the plate that it hits on right but what
i'm saying is i can't do anything
until like as far as with that because i
haven't like insurance have insurance
yeah
i heard you have it on your phone most
people do now
yeah
do you have your driver's license on you
she don't i have a job
she does i had her driving because i
normally drive you want my license
no no you don't have your license
no
okay
what is your name ma'am it's here patera
suspended for insurance yeah 10-4
i'm sorry your last name
the license in pennsylvania yeah okay
all right so you have your insurance
yeah hold on one second hold on matter
of fact let me just
did you change companies or something
yes first of all yes i changed companies
because i was with i'm with glazer now
who were you at i was with
unassigned units so here's what happens
okay when you leave one company the next
the old company sends a letter saying
they don't have insurance with us
anymore
new company is supposed to send
something and update penndot well what
they did this is what it was
we had an issue in december
was not like to say that i didn't
what you're saying i went to court and
obviously with um the department of
transportation
they proved that obviously unitron was
wrong that i did not i've never ever
laughed in my insurance you got what i'm
saying so
what happened was
it's crazy because they fix one car
which is if you look at my niece i have
a nissan if you pull out my nissan
sentra my nissan central matter of fact
surgery looking for him okay so do you
have if you look at my visa
do you have any paperwork or any
information from penndot that shows that
i actually do but it's at home but it
shows on the one vehicle so you're not
gonna have it on one vehicle why don't
you pull up your insurance for this
though
i could verify that you have insurance
that's my biggest concern
the plate being expired is minor no
insurance is something i'm not sure what
i have
i'm just trying to pull up my email okay
because she just i had her send me the
card sure
um i just got this phone so please
forgive me okay
and sergio you know how to pull that key
out and then unlock
um
just hand me hand me the the thing right
here no at the bottom
let's relax
right
[Applause]
that's for driver's license
identification
there's the registration let's see that
relax
it's okay it's okay
you can do whatever you have to do with
it we gotta do
yeah do you gotta do
she's gonna take care
all right so you pull that up and i'll
be right back okay sure
actually once you pull it up just show
it to that cop right there
yeah what do you mean
can you just search
buddy
hmm
[Applause]
hey how are you
i'm okay what do you got hold on i just
got this phone though
all right show it to him once you get it
give me a second
don't written any papers
[Applause]
so
so
[Applause]
i'm not worried about that i just said
if i had her send me
[Music]
he ripped my insurance policy to shreds
and he was this close to ripping the
title but it was completely intact not
even like thank god for that one i'm
sure it's easier to get than that um i
wouldn't was like
stuck on the floor because it looked
like a birth certificate at first like
just how i was printing i was like i
haven't purchased it that can't be it i
went in the insurance policy like the
paper was just everywhere and i'm
it was so bad i was like oh my god you
ripped it to shreds
yeah those little fingers could really
tear little pieces it it was i was very
smart i woke up like three a.m and he
was sleeping with one of the papers like
i was trying to show you guys
it was like a paper on him a paper
across the room two other papers and it
was like shreds of it and i was like
who tore this like this i was like why
is this house like i picked it up and i
was like
the general and i was like oh my god i
was like oh my god this is insurance
privacy i'm like i'm gonna go into my
yahoo mail
um
it looks like it makes google with yahoo
do you have a google okay just let's
just just download the gallery do you
know your password
yeah like okay so go to the internet
it's easy
[Applause]
like when you get it
they should send you a thing like you
can download the pdf file into your like
oh
[Music]
i don't have a choice
okay i don't have to cite you for your
suspended license i'm not going to
and if that's your child i'm not going
to take you in front of your child okay
follow me i'm just going to care for her
here's the call is this grandma
yeah but she's not able
grandma was able to help off
all right
listen
you're gonna have to beat her until
monday
i know it sucks
again i'm sorry
here's what happens is
i'm just saying if you weren't the
driver of the car i wouldn't be in this
predicament
they have been screwing me
from the beginning i cannot do this
again
i cannot
i cannot do no i cannot do this again
they have been doing this to me every
time and i have been doing my job i have
been doing my job and going to the
courts and doing what i had to do and i
just don't understand why they keep
doing this to me
why do they keep putting me in this
position
with my child
why
why do they keep doing this to me mom no
i can't go i cannot do it mom i can't
they keep doing this to me i don't
understand i don't understand why
why why don't you keep doing this in me
why
no i can't i can't i don't understand
why they keep doing this to me
i'm doing everything in my powers to
make this go away
i know i am doing i don't understand now
ourselves and i don't understand and
they never give me my medication any
time i'm being nervous i'm so sick of
this i am so sick of this i swear to god
i'm so sick of this
i swear to god i am so sick of this they
are trying to keep me
they are trying to keep me mom yes i
know they are trying to keep me and i
just don't understand why they won't
give me a fucking break
why
why
why would they keep doing this to me
i just don't understand it now yo this
is not fair
this is not fair
i can't
because it's been the third time yo
why
are you able
to do that
just relax just
relax they keep doing this to me
and i keep going to the courts and i
can't tell you what this is going on and
it's like nobody
cares they're just going to keep putting
me back in jail
and for what because i miss courtney
because they keep giving me the wrong
date
that's not true why do i keep doing this
because it's really bad and i spoke with
stephanie
i'm really involved i'm not sure
and i'm getting to the point where i'm
really getting irritated with my
daughter and with her mental health
it's really bad right like and and i
don't want to like make it a really big
thing here and i will hang it in a
minute
don't make threats about my car i told
you that
[Music]
what we're dealing with and this is
ridiculous this is the third time over
okay and i keep going to court and they
keep doing it to me what am i
i'm not threatening i'm telling you if
you don't pull the insurance off i'm
towing the car that's not a threat
you're not even crying you told my car
definitely tow my car i dig mom
you dare me
i'm just telling you if you could
produce the insurance and i'm excited
i'm a well-known respected woman here i
may look crazy right now i do not walk
around here without no
license i'm explaining it to you i'm
trying to pull it up on the phone i just
got a new phone you could see the paper
still on the phone i'm i'm trying to
pull up pull it up so i can give it to
you i don't have no reason to lie
everybody here know that worked up until
why do you keep wasting time do it
because i have to download the app do
what you have to do then come on
hold on
i
you're not worried about it
county do we have a transport coming
here
this car is chirping now
okay
there we go
think i screenshotted it
call you up calls on allen
and this is nothing like to you or
anything like that but i'm trying to
find this get my phone on this is too
much
this is just too much
and that makes absolutely no sense with
that whatever the hell he said why he
pulled come
on lights this one
this one
next
bridge
[Music]
okay
the thing is this i just got my phone
and i explained this to him i know you
you know me i know you or whatever i
i literally just got this problem
i can't pull up i am not mine i don't
have two errors but both okay
you know me i know you i know all of you
whatever
my thing is is i don't play games like
this i i'm trying to pull it up i know
that my my um agent sent me everything
in an email
i didn't bring my other phone with me
actually it's the first time i left it
can you access your uh email from your
new phone that's what i'm saying like i
have the gmail on here but she sent it
to my yahoo email
hold on let me see if i can follow and
see if rhonda's phone
hold on
let me see if she got access to it
five steps
hey brian how are you
i can um
um have my insurance because
for whatever reason they don't think
that i have insurance
and i explain to them that i have
insurance
okay
all right all right all right
okay
all right
that was my agent
do you want me to contact the insurance
agent that's only i mean i could do that
you have the app it's pretty it's tough
to do it on saturdays with the um agent
because i haven't that was hard you're
not gonna get how you get them at seven
o'clock at night that's a that's tough
you gotta download the app i'd call
somebody for a ride at this point
i'm not comfortable i'm not leaving my
car here
my car's not getting told
my car's not getting towed
because what i need to do is i need to
try to pull up my my no i'm going to try
to get this download i haven't shown you
over here you can know there's two parts
you could have insurance right you could
have the card on you right now but the
problem is when you drive with a plate
that is suspended but it's not that's
what i'm explaining
but i'm explaining to you it's not
suspended but when penndot has it
suspended so when you complete and
suspend it
he's supposed to take your plate and
send it to the pin knot and they start
suspension for three months and what i'm
explaining to you is my plate is not
suspended well he could continue when i
went to court my friends
show you i'll show it to you
i'll show it to you dan
i'm going to print her 28
don't don't call anybody because i'm
talking to alan
hello
where are you at
okay
turkey hill on hazel
i don't know
my car is going to be told because i'm
explaining to you guys are you guys
going to pay for my car to get sold out
no
you are because my car is not suspended
and i'm explaining to you it's not
suspended
i'm explaining that to you you're
explaining it but you don't have
anything to prove this at this point and
i'm explaining to you that even when i
went to court over 10 not suspended i
don't know what to tell you
i'm just getting yourself together what
you have to do please
i am
sergio rica
rika
okay
yep
come to the other side mom
okay yeah and i needed it i got my
pockets
what am i supposed to do with my
grandson
i thought for a while
this is what i need you to do okay
this is what i need you to do
listen this is what i need
danny
this is what i need you to do i have two
listen
we're basing off the license plate we
don't base it off on you know we just
base it off in that plate and what what
what they're doing at the department of
um of the i don't know what they do
there
you know i can't answer for that i just
know that your plate oh i'm showing your
food great i don't have to show you this
but i'm trying to prove that all right
um
hey
[Applause]
foreign
police
make sure
yeah just give me one second
oh my god where's your car at um
where's his car across the street
[Music]
make sure you accept it or have to do i
have to pay for the chart i don't know
you you clearly know he's aware that i'm
on the workspace police library
committee i am well known here i don't
act stupid i don't actually i'll work
for all you except for today no
i clearly said to him
i got a new phone
so i hope you see me on this camera yeah
i said i got a new phone i can't i don't
have like they take me i have um
i have a um
[Applause]
there's no way they're gonna give me
insurance if my vehicles are or um it's
not registered it's no way talk to the
state about that no and what i'm saying
is there's nobody going to do that
where's my vehicle going
okay 279 north sherman okay
when can i get my vehicle out here
okay so if i got proof of insurance if i
bring back my proof of insurance i can
go and get my vehicle
as long as you're here because my listen
sir well i'm trying to explain it on
this monday friday they pick it up right
pick up my weekends
today as long as i have insurance
yeah all right let's see what it says
does that plate on it now they just took
the plate off
i can't get the plate off maybe you guys
have a better future
what happened was when i went to court
she wants to use her positions
is
yeah bigger one
i am ready
i didn't ask her about what she does but
i already know that but i've asked her
right old boy
in the past
yep
um
[Music]
going to receive citations okay
for uh vehicle code violations
you have a suspended driver driving your
car
you have an unregistered vehicle you
have no proof of insurance
you have a suspended plate
um you have window tint
okay let me tell you something i've been
driving around with this car i don't
know how long you're trying to
and i'm not going so whatever you need
to do you do it okay whatever you need
to make sure whatever you need to do
like you said we right here so whatever
whatever you need to do you do it
absolutely so go ahead and write
whatever you need to write isn't going
to get you out of trouble
i'm not even worried about it but your
positions are going to get you fired
that's what's going to happen remember
that that's what's going to happen
remember that that's what's going to
happen okay
go ahead say what i'm going to see you
you want to be cocky you want to be
confident
and then what's going to be the charge
today that i
i don't know what the price will be on
monday
are you open tomorrow but i can welcome
tomorrow
but um uh
the manager is not backing for monday
yeah but you could still get it
if you want some time to figure out you
know like let's talk to my house i'll
put the toilet up all right
no no she's an assistant we we made her
look bad i know she's only well she
makes herself look bad it's ridiculous
that's three four red body cameras i
think
i need to know that officer's name in
charge of 10 cents for the paper and 10
cents per game
what no i can't no
here okay
oops
what's his name duffy
oh he's got a pizza here
look at him
listen
don't even worry about it thank you i
appreciate it
you want me he won't be mr cocky yep
okay
i'll hold you to it
review committee that's a good one
it's an effort disorderly too
man
bye-bye
is
give you some more nasty
oh i'm keeping mine up the whole time
i know what i'm gonna say
i'm not even gonna write anything i'm
gonna do my toe report i'm gonna send a
thing saying just review the body camera
end of story